BRIAN: Greg's coming
back now, and he's
going to show you how we use GCP
and Firebase together to really
modernize corporate IT apps.
Greg--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: Thanks, Brian.
Brian told you we're going to
take an example of an existing
on-prem application.
And we're going to modernize
it with Google Cloud.
Now, in this case, the
app that Chris and I
are going to work with is
an old ASP.NET application.
Well, that's not an
ASP.NET application.
That's an ASP.NET application.
This is an application used
by an insurance company.
So the adjusters go
out in the field.
They take their digital camera.
They take pictures
of the accidents.
They put it in their SD cards.
And then they upload the
images into the application.
It's also got an API
on it so that you
can manage all the images that
are associated with a given
claim.
Now we're going to start
bringing this application out
of the 90's and
into the modern era.
We're going to start
by giving our agents
a good mobile
application so they don't
have to lug a laptop around.
Firebase makes that super easy.
You can build a
mobile application
without having to be
a back end expert.
In this case, what
Chris is showing
you is the line of
code that integrates
Firebase with cloud storage.
So this line of code allows
the camera to take a picture.
That picture then
automatically gets
uploaded into a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
So to show this is
going to happen,
Chris is going to take a
quick photo with the phone.
CHRIS: All right,
everyone, say cheese.
I love having audiences do that.
GREG: OK.
So that photo now
is being uploaded.
And it's being stored into a
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
Now, to show that it
really is in a GCS bucket,
we're going to
switch over, we're
going to list the
contents of this bucket.
Now, the Windows
users among you are
going to notice that
he's using PowerShell.
That's because he's using
cloud tools for PowerShell.
It gives windows developers
a first class experience
using Google Cloud Platform with
the services that they love.
And sure enough,
there's the picture.
It was just uploaded today.
So now we've got a
claim picture in GCS.
How do we get it to this
old legacy application?
Apogee and cloud functions
make that simple.
The good news is our legacy
app has an API, as I mentioned.
The bad news is the app was
written over a decade ago
so it's a SOAP API.
So it's not really very friendly
to modern RESTful developer
like Chris.
Apogee, however, is an
enterprise API management
platform.
And we're going
to start by using
it to create a proxy to
convert this legacy SOAP
XML into modern JSON.
So here's the Apogee console.
We've connected it to
the WSDL of the service.
I can't believe I'm
saying that in 2017.
[LAUGHTER]
And on the left side
you see the SOAP XML.
And on the right side,
Apogee is automatically
created a much friendlier,
easier for the developer
to use, JSON version of it.
Now Apogee has a lot
of other capabilities.
So in addition to
doing that, Chris
has applied a quota, so that we
don't flood this poor service
with millions of mobile agents
all trying to upload photos
at the same time.
It automatically
provides throttling.
We've also put
authentication in so
that only our agents and only
those mobile applications
can upload the data.
Apogee has got tons
more capabilities.
I am only scratching
the surface.
But for our purposes that's good
enough for this application.
So we got images in a bucket.
We got our
application that's now
got a nice modern API on it.
How do we connect the two?
Well, I could deploy a VM,
but that's overkill, right?
All I want to do is copy a
little file from GCS to an API.
Why should I pick an operating
system and have to patch the OS
and deploy a big heavy VM image?
Cloud functions allows
me to just write
a snippet of JavaScript.
This JavaScript is listening
to that GCS bucket.
So anytime a file gets added,
this snippet gets invoked.
And if it goes down,
you'll see he's
using the post method, that
nice RESTful interface,
onto our web service.
So now when Chris
takes a picture,
we should see the picture
go all the way through.
Now, I don't have a car
crash on stage, Chris.
I think you've got
though some sort
of a next best thing for us.
CHRIS: Actually, what
I'm prepared to do,
Greg, is, I've got some scale
model vehicle replicas here
that I'm going to use to
simulate a high speed collision
scenario.
GREG: This is scaled down into--
CHRIS: Exactly right.
GREG: Very good.
CHRIS: You're ready?
GREG: Yeah, go for it.
CHRIS: [SOUNDS OF A CAR CRASH]
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: Please tell me you
didn't misplace the phone.
So he's going to take the
picture of-- oh, the humanity.
And it gets uploaded.
And now he's going
to switch back
to our application,
our corporate app.
He's going to hit F5
because it's the 90s
and we have to refresh.
And there we go.
There's our application.
[APPLAUSE]
We started with the
legacy on-prem app.
We used Firebase to build a
mobile application that didn't
even require a back end expert.
We wrapped the old SOAP API and
modern JSON and cloud functions
with this wonderful glue layer
to connect everything together.
But one more thing,
this application
started as an
on-prem application.
And we've wrapped it with
all this amazing cloud stuff,
but it's still sitting on-prem.
Let's fix that bug too.
With just a couple
of clicks, Chris
will start the the Migration
Wizard and in about 45 minutes
we will live migrate
this running service
into Google Cloud
Platform, where
it runs on Google's amazing
infrastructure network
operations and reliability.
And now we've really
taken this app
and brought it into
the modern era.